يسارع رجال الانقاذ لمساعده السكان
ومعاينه الاضرار بعد ان سقط حطام طائره
مسيره فوق مبنى في كيف هذا الاستهداف ليس
الا واحدا من سلسله ضربات جويه روسيه طالت
المدن الاوكرانيه السلطات في كيف وصفت
الهجوم بالضم وقالت انه استهدف بنيه تحتيه
اجتماعيه وحيويه في العديد من المدن
الكبرى كيف وخاركوف والفيف
واوديسا مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني قال ان
الهجوم يثبت ان بلاده بحاجه الى المزيد من
مساعده المجتمع الدولي فالمسؤولون
الاوكرانيين يخشون من تراجع زخم الدعم
الغربي لبلدهم ولا سما مع اخفاق الهجوم
المضاد الاوكراني في دحر القوات الروسيه
عند خطوط
مواجهه يتحرك هؤلاء الجنود الاوكرانيين
بصعوبه بين الوحل والالغام في ايار مايو
الماضي سيطرت القوات الروسيه على بلده بخم
التي تبعد عره كيلومترات عن هذا الموقع
ومنذ ذلك الحين لا تتوقف الهجمات الروسيه
يهاجم مواقعنا باستمرار وهذا مرهق لجنود
المشد هم يتقدمون بغض النظر عن الطقس
والاوحد لذلك الارض مغطاه
بجثثهم في الاسابيع الاخيره تقدمت القوات
الروسيه في منطقه دونباس وقالت ان جنودها
سيطروا على قريه مارينكا يوم الاثنين
وحققوا مكاسب ميدانيه في منطقه اخرى هي
افدي فكا الاوكرانيين يؤكدون ان التقدم
الروسي يحدث على حساب خسائر بشريه تقدر
بالالاف امام اصرار موسكو تحتاج ايضا
للتشبث بمواقعها على الرغم من فتور الدعم
الغربي تقرير صدر عن معهد كيل اظهر ان
المساعدات المقدمه لكيف انخفضت بين اب
اغسطس وتشرين الاول اكتوبر بنسبه 90 في
لدى مقارنتها بالفتره نفسها من العام
الماضي